déjà moi ce qui me fascine c'est chez
les ch et des politiques c'est que ils
ont une faculté à parler des choses
qu'ils ne connaissent pas c'est ce que
je disais en fait dans
sur cette phrase lorsque ce qui marque
c'est que vous parlez des quartiers et
des banlieues mais à je doute
réellement un votre implication dans les
quartiers ce que l'on connaissait pas
est ce que vous avez à vous y allez
constamment là écoutez moi je sais que
vous avez grandi dans les tours marron
de l'haÿ les roses et je sais que vous
étiez un petit peu plus jeune que le
nouveau maire aujourd'hui de
l'haÿ-les-roses vincent jean - qui est
un mets très très proche et qui m'emmène
avec lui dans les quartiers vous allez
relever rose laurens portelli voyez l
élu de taverny et quand j'étais jeune
député j'étais député des yvelines elle
m'a emmené prendre le thé chez les
mamans de son quartier populaire pour
justement discuter avec l égalité des
chances comment est-ce qu'on aide leurs
enfants à réussir à l'école comment est
ce qu'on fait comment est-ce qu'on
implique les mamans dans l'éducation des
enfants comme on sait de l'aide à la
parentalité
othman qui est derrière vous othman
nasri moi je les repérer un jour alors
ils manifester contre moi est ce que
vivra comptera non mais il est d'autres
avril et de trappes mais il m'emmène à
trappes boire le thé mais je ne vais pas
seulement j'ai passé à mettre un pied
dans les quartiers mais attendez on tire
c'est comme si moi je vais à l'assemblée
nationale et je dis ah bah je suis un
jeu peu près la bure est installé non
aujourd'hui cyril il m'a invité pour
parler de banlieue il sait très bien
qu'il m'a pas invité pour parler
politique parce que c'est pas un sujet
comme ça veut dire quoi c'est dire qu'il
faudrait que j'y habite au pouvoir en
parler sinon j'aime ma loi pas du tout
merci quand même ce que je dis c'est que
en fait un vous dites par exemple il
faut ressortir les kärcher y a plus
droit à une deuxième chance je sais pas
non j'ai pas dit ça bah droit est ma
deuxième jeune homme est une peine
plancher sais quoi est une peine
plancher ses meetings plein automatique
effectivement quand on est
multirécidiviste il ya un moment il faut
que ça s'arrête la violence quand même
parce que les habitants des quartiers
moi je les voie moi je les rencontre
vous savez j'ai fait j'ai pris une
décision quand même vous dites et
quartier j'ai pris une décision le siège
de la région ile de france ma région
vous savez où ils étaient avant il était
en face de l'hôtel de matignon en face
de là où est le premier ministre moi
j'ai décidé déménager tout le monde j'ai
déménagé 3000 personnes habitant dans
les quartiers à saint-ouen on est à
saint thois on est à trois cents mètres
d'accord d'un quartier qui s'appelle un
quartier de reconquête républicaine
c'est à dire en réalité pas un quartier
de deals defour bon et un quartier dans
lesquelles il ya de la violence et où on
a aussi on a aussi des personnes qui
meurent chaque année chaque année des
victimes de ces trafics parce que dans
les trafics il ya des guerres de gangs
et on le sait donc pourquoi moi j'ai moi
j'ai lu reçu les mamans ce que les
mamans combattants voix banlieue sud qui
se mobilise trois banlieues et tout de
suite donc j'ai pas dis banlieue et
outils d'un bon pied du deal a tout de
suite moi j'ai dit je suis installé à
saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis avait
pas de souci est la région pourquoi
pourquoi ce que j'ai vu des gens qui
sont là qui soutiennent qu'ils sont
ensemble unis dans tous les quartiers
c'est comme ça et bien c'est pour ce
faire tu as du deal vous savez moi ce
que je dis souvent c'est que dans les
banlieues les banlieues c'est comme la
politique il ya des bons et des mauvais
en fait la bestiole et c'est partout et
bien c'est la même chose sauf que dans
les quartiers a plus de bons que dans la
politique vraiment non mais réellement
réellement parce que en fait non c'est
réel c'est réel vous pouvez dire oh mais
franchement c'est réel parce que nous on
a vraiment cette entraide on a vraiment
cette solidarité on a vraiment un coeur
on veut vraiment donner sans attendre en
retour et le problème de la politique
c'est vraiment mais on al'impression
vraiment que tout est calculé qu'est ce
que vous avez fait pour les quartiers et
ben écoutez moi aujourd'hui c'est ce que
je trouve ça fou c'est le fait de mettre
la région ça vous paraît ça vous parle
pas en seine-saint-denis c'est quand
même dire que je les respecte ça veut
dire que je les aime ça veut dire que je
veux être au milieu au milieu des
quartiers les plus populaires je veux
qu'ils soient fiers que le siège de la
région ce soit plus dans paris que ce
soit avec eux qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour les quartiers je passe j'ai une
politique aujourd'hui pour rénover les
quartiers on l'a mis 250 millions
d'euros sur la rénovation urbaine qu'est
ce qu'on fait là on est au delà même des
commerces on amène on amène des espaces
verts ont reconstruit moi j'ai un plan
j'ai un plan je veux qu'en dix ans les
tous les grands ensembles on puisse les
transformer en vrai quartier de ville en
vrai quartier de ville avec des espaces
verts en vrai quartier avec des services
publics que malheureusement on sait bien
dans les quartiers populaires il ya des
déserts médicaux dans les quartiers
populaires il ya moins de commerce donc
moi je veux ça et je veux aussi faire un
plan pour l'égalité des chances je vous
donne un exemple très concret parce que
on parle mais vous allez me dire c'est
pas assez concret moi je suis rendu
compte en allant dialoguer avec les
jeunes talents le délégué jeunes dans
les quartiers populaires et dans les
lycées des quartiers populaires qu'il y
avait des signes qui parce qu'elle
n'avait pas les moyens ne venez pas en
cours quand elles avaient leurs règles
elle venait pas au cours parce qu'elle
n'avait pas de quoi se payer les
protections périodiques nécessaire
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a mis en place
dans tous les lycées d'île de france des
distributeurs gratuit de protections
périodiques c'est un exemple très
concret de ce qu'on fait pour que pour
l'égalité des chances mais de la même
façon moi j'ai mis en place toute une 6
tout un système de bourse je veux cent
mille logements pour les étudiants je
veux que tous les jeunes de france aient
la même chance de réussir dans la
société française et je le fais et je le
fais avec les jeunes des quartiers
populaires comme encore plus mais est ce
que vous vous rendez compte de ce que
vous me dites moi pourquoi je suis en
train de vous dire qu'est ce que vous
avez fait pour les banlieues vous ne
parlez nova sur bet rénovation urbaine
égalité des chances en maintenant l
égalité des choses concrètes non
concrètement non concrètement situation
concrète défi je vous parle je vous
parle de la vie quotidienne aujourd'hui
ce que vous attendez qu'on répond ce la
malle bas j'attendais concrètes en fait
entre la politique et la banlieue ya
vraiment un fossé
thaler série de la très bien dit cemac
rond et on ne sait pas qui aura en face
voilà on va on va prendre le moins pire
on va dire nous en banlieue pourquoi on
n'est pas affilié avec la politique et
on comprend rien en fait de la politique
parce que y'a personne réellement qui
nous représente il ya personne
réellement en fait les politiques
généralement ils parlent mais ils ne
font pas ils n'agissent pas ils viennent
dans nos quartiers cancellé les
élections ils viennent ils font les
beaux à moi c'est pas moi c'est pas le
cas moi c'est tous les jours aujourd'hui
m city stade vous aimez le foot on vole
on this city stade ya pas de problème
hop voter pour moi aux actifs moi j'ai
financé nuit l'équipement sportif pur
jus lutte est justement le fait qu'il en
avait pas dans les quartiers sur les
entrepreneurs des cités j'ai donné j'ai
demandé j'ai demandé que y ait vraiment
eu un souk à une focale dans toutes les
aides aux entreprises ou à la création
d'entreprise pour mais qu'il faut cale
sur les quartiers populaires parce que
il a une dynamique entrepreneuriale
extrêmement fort dans les quartiers et
j'ai demandé aussi qu'on aide les femmes
des quartiers parce que l d'eau si elles
doivent être plus serré donc franchement
sur ces sujets de quartiers populaires
la région ile-de-france a mis 2
milliards d'euros pour faire en sorte
que les que les habitants des quartiers
se sont considérés et respectés autant
que les habitants des centres villes
quand vous dites et on a amené aussi la
culture jamal normal juste la malgache
et a dit un truc intéressant et un
instant pour toi c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas un candidat qui parle aux banlieues
politique
c'est la personne et à la personne parce
qu'ils sont tous pareils en fait il y en
a cela prendra dès aujourd'hui du
répertoire de la beauté
sans hésitation je sais pas quand je
vais voter blanc d'accord c'est ça ouais
je vais voter blanc je fournirai mais
réellement parce que en vrai
sincèrement des fois quand j'entends des
fois mélenchon qui parle je me dis ah
c'est pas mal après je voyais film
dinguerie jeudi
mais truc je peux entendre des fois
valérie humainement tout je me suis dit
mais en fait après j'entends qu'il faut
sortir tant de gens derrière il faut
sortir les cacher je me suis mais
qu'est-ce que mais c'est contre les
voyous c'est dur aider les habitants
parce que les habitants ils ont droit à
la sécurité aussi mais moi j'habite en
banlieue et j'habite dans un quartier et
je vous garantis que tous les habitants
non je vais pas dire tous les habitants
ça serait mentir la majorité les
habitants ici plaisent on les aide quand
je dis moi je suis un jeune de quartier
j'ai traîné en bas des halls et c'est
trop vous avez fait de la prison de
calamane pour trafic de stupéfiants
d'accord ça c'est un très gros trafic de
stupéfiants
à travers cette version car séries comme
maintenant quatre ans 80 d'accord voilà
donc en vrai nous on est là on va voir
la trafic de stupéfiants très bien
trafic de stupéfiants j'étais un dealer
et s'arrêtaient pas de moi une personne
qui n'était pas une personne qui
habitait dans le quartier monts et les
hauts lieux et d apporter ses courses on
nous faisait plein de choses on lui
tenait la porte plein de choses comme ça
plein de petites choses qui peuvent
paraître anodines et banale mais
justement on en parle on en parle les
ascenseurs dans les hlm moi j'ai mis en
place un plan parce qu'aujourd'hui les
hlm les ascenseurs était cassé j'ai mis
en place j'étais soulagé car
j'ai pas eu d dit que vous les casiers
j'ai dit que les quartiers étaient
souvent abandonnées et que la région a
dû venir pour aider à réparer les
ascenseurs la politique au liban lieu
donc moi j'ai fait déjà comme la
critique à beaune laborieux est
réellement pourquoi je dis ça parce que
concrètement dans tous les mois cyril tu
te disais alors dans tous les candidats
que je vois quand j'écoute leurs
programmes ou autre je veux pas trop
parler de politique parce que c'est pas
je maîtrise pas ce sujet donc je vais
pas m'inventer de vie mais en vrai quand
je vois la voix la voix la majorité des
politiques et ben soit c'est l'islam
soit c'est en fait ils ont tous à un
truc que ça ne parle pas il n'y a aucun
aucun service donc quand je vous dis si
je vous dis si je vous dis la bouche que
vous dites là mal c'est par élimination
c'est ou blanc ou
quoi ou le président ben vrai
j'aime bien mélenchon quand même oui
j'aime bien mélenchon j'aime bien
mélenchon parce que en fait pourquoi
j'aime bien mélenchon parce que j'ai
l'impression
j'ai l'impression j'ai bien dit
l'impression mais ça reste un politique
donc en bref j'ai pas confiance mais
j'ai l'impression que lui va sur le
terrain
et la même impression il n'a pas un euro
1 pour faire ses promesses a pas un euro
manon à toi tout le monde je parle pas
de son programme wash dc2 les jours et
je vois j'ai des gros yeux je vois mais
que tout le monde en plus donc quand je
vois mélenchon aller sur le terrain
parler peut-être qu'après ça c'est un
très beau comédien et qu'il arrive à
peut-être qu'ils pourraient jouer dans
une pièce de théâtre je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas quand je le vois aller sur
le terrain je le vois 2e
tu vois il parle avec ses tripes il
parle avec eux donc j'ai l'impression
j'ai bien aimé jacquet la malle moyens
un sujet qu'on parle de prison puis on
parle de prison et de deuxième chance
moi tout mon projet il est basé sur
l'école et l'égalité des chances tout
mon projet moi mon objectif c'est de
lutter contre les inégalités scolaires
on a le l'école la plus inégalitaire et
ça c'est un vrai sujet notamment pour
les quartiers populaires donc moi je
mets les fondamentaux coeur le français
les maths j'aide les jeunes qui
décrochent je fais je les appelle au
téléphone c'est ça que j'ai mis en place
j'appelle tous les jeunes décrocheurs
pour les raccrocher pour trouver une
solution pour chaque jeune pour qu' il
soit pas décrocheurs et qu'ils aillent
pas tenir les murs ou se retrouver
devant des dents des dents des réseaux
il faut dire je les amène conférés je
veux je veux moi je veux aujourd'hui qu'
un soutien scolaire gratuit pour toutes
les familles et je veux aussi que les
régions fassent l'orientation des jeunes
je mettrai en place un revenu jeune
actif pour que les jeunes puissent aller
dans les métiers qui recrutent et qu'on
les forme à ces métiers qui recrutent
parce que je veux qu'ils réussissent
donc c'est au coeur de mon projet et
puisque vous avez été en prison ben moi
j'ai fait pour les prisons un plan de
formation des détenus parce que quand je
suis arrivé à la tête de la région
il n'y avait pas de vrai droit à la
seconde chance et pas dans les droits la
seconde chance en prison parce que
l'éducation nationale elle n'avait pas
les diplômes fait pour donc on n'avait
pas de vrai programme de réinsertion des
détenus et moi je voulais la formation
pour les jeunes détenus pour qu'ils
aient un droit à la deuxième chance
parce que la réinsertion c'est vous vous
avez réussi votre réinsertion parce que
vous avez vous êtes devenu célèbre mais
pour pour une personne qui devient
célèbre et qui serait un cerf combien il
ya de jeunes qu'on n'arrive pas à sortir
une fois la prison c'est celle là il
faudrait insister cela mal les banlieues
et justement pour les emplois pour les
inciter à trouver du travail parce que
je vous dis je vous dis la vérité un
lama il y en a combien on n'a pas
beaucoup mais samassa et samassa qui
s'est passé que jamais la force à la
vente avant de te libérer est ce
qu'aujourd'hui en rencontrant valérie
pécresse tu peux voilà changé d'avis sur
ton brunch je pourrais pas changé d'avis
sur les politiques parce que comme je
t'ai dit c'est compliqué après celle là
tu nous as dit que j'allais bien
mélenchon est ce que tu veux changer
d'avis ou pas du tout en vrai j'ai rien
vraiment contre 1 valérie pécresse ou
autre mais ce que j'entends quand moi je
suis chez moi et que j'entends font
ressortir des cars cher faut faire ceci
il faut faire ça donc ça a était
éliminatoire pour toi pourrez tout de
suite je me dis onu moi je vis dans les
banlieues donc un pâle de karcher je me
dis à temps je suis dans les banlieues
je suis une bonne personne mais j'habite
en banlieue parce que malheureusement je
suis pas né avec une cuillère en or dans
la bouche ça peut arriver j'habite juste
en banlieue c'est pas un truc de ouf
mais ce que j'ai l'impression vraiment
c'est que les politiques vous vos
programmes ou autre parle à la france
mais une autre france alors que pour moi
chaque français est important merci lama
mais moi oui si chaque français est
important et c'est pour ça que je veux
un plan sur 10 ans pour que on refasse
des quartiers et résidant au quartier
moi j'veux du beau du bon et je veux de
l'espoir partout en france donc je
compris dans les quartiers populaires ou
sur dix ans sur dix ans de mandat
d'aucuns canard ben oui mais construire
et détruire des tours des bars et pour
reconstruire des immeubles à taille
humaine pour remettre des espaces verts
remettre de l'emploi et de la réussite
il faut sans se mettre se projeter sur
dix mâles
[Applaudissements]
comme je disais tout à l'heure entre la
politique et la banlieue ya vraiment un
fossé et ce qui serait bien aussi si
vous êtes élu ce que je vous souhaite
aussi quand même parce que je souhaite
le bien je suis un mec de banlieue
méchante le bien pour les ans
est vrai ça serait de de raccorder comme
dans une course de
l'athlétisme un peu avant les passages
de témoins exactement donc en vrai
raccorder la politique avec la banlieue
pour que la banlieue s'intéresse un peu
plus à la politique c'est un personnel
ammann a raison c'est qu'il faut aussi
qu'on ait des élus qui ressemble à la
france mais oui et moi j'ai vraiment
voulu faire ça dans mes équipes
régionales j'ai voulu essayer de faire
monter des jeunes des jeunes de
quartiers actionnaires pour en parler
avait comme un devoir pour pouvoir pour
qu'il puisse représenter vraiment la
banlieue
[Applaudissements]